hi everyone i'm bryn moore and today
pikachu and i will be presenting joint
work with my advisor ryan on smaller acc
0 circuits for symmetric functions
first a brief introduction
this work studies the power of mod gates
which count modulosome natural number n
in particular we study two complexity
classes
cc0
and acc0
okay so what are these complexity
classes
many of you may already be familiar with
the complexity class ac0
these are functions computable with
constant depth circuit families
with unbounded fan in
and an or gates
we allow any of these gates to be
negated freely so negations will not
contribute to either circuit size or
depth
now if we change this definition
slightly and also allow mod gates
we get the complexity class acc0
it's worth noting here that the modulus
m for the mod gates may vary with the
circuit family or with the function
being computed but it may not depend on
the input size
for contrast in the complexity class ac0
mod m
the modulus n is fixed even across
circuit families
and finally if we only allow the mod
gates we get the complexity class cc0
and again the modulus m may not depend
on the input size but it may depend on
the circuit family
now one question we could ask
is how do these mod gates help what is
the power of these mod gates
can they for instance
efficiently compute symmetric functions
like majority
it's well known that in ac0
this requires exponential size
also ac 0 mod m also requires
superpolynomial size when m is a prime
power
however
little is known about non-prime power
moduli
for instance it has been conjectured for
years that the and function does not
have polynomial size cc0 circuits
but it's still an open question
whether not just and
but even any problem decidable in
exponential time can be computed with a
polynomial size circuit family even if
you only allow mod six gates and depth
three
so this is a kind of embarrassing open
problem right
but proving such lower bounds is
difficult
and we shed some light on this
difficulty by showing that cc0 may
actually be more powerful than we
previously thought
so here's an overview of our results
our first result is that every symmetric
function can be computed by depth 3 cc0
circuits of sub-exponential size
so for every epsilon
there's a modulus m such that every
symmetric function on n bits
can be computed by depth 3 mod m
circuits
of size exponential in n to the epsilon
and in fact these circuits have a nice
form
they've got the form mod p1 of mod p2 by
p3 by etc up to p r
of mod p1
where all of these pi's are distinct
primes
and we also show a trade-off between
circuit size circuit depth and the
number r of prime factors of the modulus
n
we can fairly easily get an additive
dependence on r and d in the double
exponent from the previous slide
so if d is at least three
and m is a product of r at least two
distinct primes
then every symmetric function on n bits
can be computed by depth d mod m
circuits
of size exponential in n to the one over
r plus d minus three
and with a little more work we can get a
multiplicative dependence
so we have a universal constant c
such that for all sufficiently large
depths
uh d and all composite m with r prime
factors
every symmetric function can be computed
by a mod m gate circuit
of depth d and size exponential in
approximately
n to the c over d times r
and i won't actually go over this result
because we can actually both improve and
simplify it significantly
if we use acc0
okay
so if we allow and and or gates as well
we can get even smaller circuits
so we'll get a trade-off similar to the
last theorem
but the construction is simpler and we
get better constants in the double
exponent
so if m is a good product of r primes
so i won't go over what exactly that
means it's a technical technical
condition but it's fairly easy to
satisfy
for every symmetric function f on n
inputs and every depth d
uh congruent to one modulo three
uh when that's not true you change the
constants a little bit
there exists an ac0 mod m circuit of
depth d
and size exponential and n to the three
over r plus d times d minus one minus
three computing f
uh our results combine results from the
literature in new ways so first i'll
give an intuitive overview of the proofs
and for the rest of the presentation
i'll be suppressing some constants and
log factors for the sake of simplicity
so if something seems a little bit off
it might actually be a little bit off
okay so intuitively our constructions
are based on the following ac0
construction
we'll focus without loss of generality
on the exact majority function image
which you might also have seen as a
exact threshold ethr
which outputs one if and only if the sum
of its inputs is exactly some threshold
t
and we'll see in a moment why this
doesn't lose generality
we're going to set a parameter delta
which should be between 0 and 1
and we're going to partition our input
bits
into
uh t groups where t is n to the delta
of
n to the one minus delta inputs each
now our circuit is going to look like
this
we're going to take a big or
over all possible vectors bold t
whose l1 norm is the threshold d
and this is why we don't lose generality
by considering only image
because every symmetric function is just
an or of up to n image functions
and so if we allow an arbitrary
symmetric function we're just increasing
the fanon of this top or gate by about a
factor of n
and each input to the score
will be an and
over all indices j
from 1 to n to the delta
and
each
input to these ands
will be a cnf that determines whether
the inputs in group j
sum to exactly
uh t sub j
and if you'll notice
uh in order to balance the fanons we'll
want to set delta to be one half
and this way the the top or will have
fannin uh two to the root n
the and gates of the c and f's can then
be collapsed into the second layer of
and gates
and so then we'll have ands of fannin
also 2 to the root n
and then the bottom layer of or gates
we'll have fan in root n
and so overall we're going to get a
circuit of size 2 to the root n
now if we allow mod gates we can improve
the construction in the following way
first we'll want to replace the top ore
with a mod gate
next instead of cnf circuits we'll want
to use much smaller mod circuits
and this will allow us to decrease delta
rebalance the fanons and get a smaller
circuit overall
but then this will leave us with the
layer of ands of mods
and so we'll want to convert that into
mods of mods
and finally we'll collapse
consecutive layers of mod gates into a
single mod layer
now as an example
let's look at the construction when we
let m be 30.
so this will work when our desired
epsilon is at least one-third
so we're going to take a delta to be
one-third also
and for smaller epsilon the construction
is essentially the same and i'll briefly
note what changes
so our theorem is as follows
every symmetric boolean function on n
variables
has a depth 3 circuit
of the form mod 5 of mod 6 of mod 5
the size exponential in n to the one
third
and uh furthermore
the output gate is just going to be a
linear sum which will always evaluate to
either 0 or 1 modulo 5
rather than a general mod 5 gate
now if we have r prime factors
we instead take delta to be 1 over r
mod 5 becomes mod p
for some prime factor p of m
and mod 6 becomes mod m over p
and this will handle any epsilon down to
one over r
now we're going to start with the ac0
construction we saw earlier
so we've got this or of ands of cnfs
and
first
we observe that at most one of the
inputs to the top or gate can ever be
true
and so we can just freely replace this
or gate with a mod 5 gate
and so this gives us our
a mod 5 of anns of cnfs
and next we'll want to replace these
ciks
with smaller mod circuits
now in order to do this we're going to
make use of the following theorem
so this is due to
edward luca and dates back to the 19th
century
so if we have a prime p
and a natural number n
then if we take
uh n choose p to the i
and reduce that modulo p
we're going to get the i
digit for lack of a better word
in the pre representation of n
now in order to replace our cnfs with
mod circuits
we're going to want to make use of a
polynomial that will evaluate to 0
modulus 6
if and only if it's input sum to a
threshold t
so we'll consider the elementary
symmetric polynomials
e sub j of degree j
by luca's theorem
if j is p to the i
and this is just the ith digit in the
pre expansion of the sum of the input
bits
and so we'll now take the following
polynomials
in this polynomial p2
these b naughts through b sub s minus 1
will be half of the bits of the brefold
t
and specifically the lower order half of
the
of these
bits now if we think about what p2 is
doing
each of these e sub j minus e sub 2 to
the j of y
will evaluate to 0
modulo 2. if and only if
the jth bit of the input sum is the same
as the jth bit of t
and so this product
will be 1
if and only if all of the low order bits
of the input sum match the low order
bits of t
and so p2 as a whole will evaluate to 0
modulo 2
if and only if all of the low order bits
of the input sum match the low order
bits of t
and similarly we'll also take this
polynomial p3
which will do the same
the same thing except
modulo 3 and in ternary
so this will evaluate to 0 modulo 3 if
all of the low order traits of the input
sum match the low order traits of t
and we can then use the chinese
remainder theorem to combine these into
the polynomial 3p2 plus 2p3
and this will evaluate to 0
uh mod 2 and mod 3 sort of it'll
evaluate to 0 modulo 6
if and only if the input sum is exactly
t
and finally we note that since
2 to the s and 3 to the t
are both root n the degree of this
polynomial is also root n
and if there are more prime factors q of
our modulus n
we just include more polynomials p sub q
and this square here in piece of three
becomes an exponent of q q minus one
instead of two
okay so now we can use the theorem we
just proved
instead of c and f's we'll use the mod 6
polynomials we just constructed
which can actually be represented by mod
6 of ans
so now our circuit looks like this we've
got a mod 5 of ands of mod 6 of ands
and the mod layers have found in two to
the n to the one third
and the and layers have found an n to
the one third
now if you recall our next step will be
to remove these and gates
okay so how do we do that
in order to remove the and gates we'll
use this result from chan and papa
constantino
which they called linearization
if we have an and of mod b gates
we can replace it with a mod a of mod b
gates
as long as a and b are co-prime
and this will incur an exponential
increase in the fan end of the of the
top gate
uh
and this mod a of mod b circuit
actually has a nice form
uh
the output gate will actually just be a
sum modulo a rather than a general mod a
gate
so all of its inputs will sum to either
0 or 1 modulo a
so now we can use this on our and layers
we'll linearize the and layers
replacing the middle ands with mod fives
and the bottom ands with mod sixes
now if you'll notice we don't actually
want to
we actually want to linearize ands of
mods
and the bottom layer doesn't have this
form
but we can just add a dummy layer of mod
5 gates underneath these ands
and then everything will work
so we end up with this
mod 5 of mod 5 sums
of mod 6 of mod 6 sons
of mod 5.
now finally since the second and fourth
layers are actually sums
we can collapse them into the top layer
in the third layer
and we get our mod 5 of mod 6 of mod 5s
as we desired
now if you'll notice we're computing
image at the bottom layer
which is itself a symmetric function
so if we allow larger depths we can
actually iterate this construction
for instance if we allow depth 4
we can get a mod 5 of mod 6 of mod 5 of
mod 6's of size exponential in n to the
1 4th
more generally we can get a double
exponent of one over r plus d minus
three
if we allow depth d and have r prime
factors in our modulus n
okay
so if you recall
uh if d is an integer at least three
and m is a product of r distinct primes
at least two
then every symmetric function on n bits
can be computed by depth d modem
circuits
of size exponential and n to the one
over r plus d minus three
and as i hinted at a moment ago
the proof is essentially by induction
we're going to iterate the construction
that i just showed
and if we additionally allow and and or
gates
we can get a multiplicative dependence
on r and d in the double exponent
instead of an additive dependence
so if we let m be a good product of r
primes
so
uh
this is a technical condition which
which
is fairly easy to satisfy but i won't
say exactly what it is
uh
then for every symmetric function f on n
inputs
and every depth d
uh congruent to one modulo three
there exists an ac zero mod m circuit
depth d and size exponential in
n to the three over uh r plus three
times d minus 1 minus 3
which will compute f
and at a high level
we're going to
prove this by using arithmetic circuits
over finite fields
to compute those elementary symmetric
polynomials that we were using earlier
and we can then simulate the arithmetic
operations using mod p gates for
addition mode p and mod p minus one
gates for multiplication mod p
and it's not entirely obvious from this
outline but we do actually make use of
acc0 here
not just cc0
now a natural extension of this work
would be to study what other
non-symmetric functions can be computed
similarly using mod gates
uh and our construction freely yields
some extensions uh such as
uh
a mod of symmetric functions
but uh could we also construct
smaller circuits to simulate say nc1
boolean formulas
or space bounded computation
and the the last of these in particular
could likely yield better lower bounds
for pp or for ph so that could be quite
interesting
also are these trade-offs optimal
and we actually show that under a fairly
natural strengthening of the hypothesis
that tc0 is not contained in acc0
the answer is yes our constructions are
essentially optimal
so it would be interesting to prove this
hypothesis or to refute it for that
matter
and that's all i have so thank you for
listening or watching
you